he smile och balut is doing all he can
to stop young Kurds from joining the PKK
and taking up arms he's a human rights
activist and he drives to the local
villages surrounding his hometown hikari
everyday but first he has to gain the
trust of the town's elders young people
listen to them Aqualad begins in the
mountain village of sumang he believes
the peace process between the Turks and
Kurds deserves another chance look at us
nothing sooner or later both sides will
have to sit down at the table and talk
why not now before thousands die again
the peace process held for two years
fighting came to a halt even here on the
border with Iran but now attention is
high sumon sits right next to a military
base you've heard a quick sheep are up
in the hills if we go up there we're
afraid we'll get shot we're sick and
tired of this if they want war that's
what they'll get
and war has been raging again a few
kilometers away from the village the
Turkish military has set up a roadblock
a bomb exploded here a couple of nights
ago young Kurds believe resistance is
legitimate piece didn't lift them out of
poverty these youths are stacking
compressed cow dung which is used to
provide heating in winter winning over
the young generation is easy work for
the PKK general five everyday combat
helicopters fly over our houses people
are arrested and if you cross the road a
bomb might go off we're tired of it all
we might not be able to defeat them but
they won't get the better of us either
uploads hometown hikari seems peaceful
enough but despite the semblance of
normality residents are still reluctant
to leave their homes the situation is
reminiscent of the 1990s when there was
a state of emergency in the Kurdish
district the military and police
tortured residents and burned villages
to the ground hundreds of Kurds
disappeared that's the trouble Stevie
soldiers seized this man along with
seven other shepherds and farmers in
1996 they were probably killed but their
bodies were never found war has returned
to the Kurdish regions in Turkey these
days peace activists like I smile aqua
loot are very rare